[Music]
what are your thoughts on bulk food
stores like costco or sam's club burnham
[Laughter]
it's a real gift and a curse right yeah
because what an amazing privilege that
we have access to bulk supplies at a
discount
right
and it makes sense if you're buying in
bulk
you use less packaging
there's also less display in stores like
that relative to like a target or
even a walmart where where they have
giant pallets of things and so they're
able to sort of
take the economy of it all and and
and save you money but also
it forces you to buy more of a product
right and if you don't need that much
then you're over consuming in a way
you're inadvertently hoarding
excess stuff right now ryan and i have
this
rule called the just for win rule it
helps you identify it's different from
the just in case rule both of these are
in the minimalist rule book the
minimalists.com
rulebook if you want to download it for
free but the just for win rule says i
buy certain things usually consumables
and i will overbuy them
because i know i'm going to use them so
i'm buying them just for when i need
them
and sam's club and costco are great
places to buy certain just for win items
as long as i have enough space for them
yeah and so i don't want to buy a pallet
of toilet paper i don't have the space
for a pallet of toilet paper right but i
do have enough space for a 24-pack of
toilet paper so i tend to buy a 24-pack
or an 18-pack and it's way more than i
need today hopefully
but i know i'm certain that i will
use the kind that i use until we are low
and then i'll buy another bulk supply
again
but i have a boundary it's whatever fits
in the sink uh underneath or in in my
bathroom keep your toilet paper in the
sink
it's the worst place to keep it it's
really wet it barely even works man it's
terrible you don't just get wipeys right
like
i guess i should be buying so much
oh man yeah i mean mariah and i uh we
don't shop at costco because it's just
the two of us yeah but i know you know i
know minimalist families that go to
costco because
they're they have a whole family so like
it makes sense to buy in bulk and so
what's our perspective on it
it all depends yeah but if you show up
there and you're making impulse buys
at a
bulk food section yeah that's the worst
thing right because i don't even eat
ramen noodles but what a great deal yeah
well now you're buying an unhealthy
thing that is actually doing a
disservice to you and now you're buying
it not just one of them and eating at
one time you're buying a case of the
unhealthy thing yeah and so if it's
forcing you to buy things that you
wouldn't typically buy because it's
quote on sale or
it is quote discounted
well it's 100 off
if you leave it on the shelf yeah did
you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit
patreon.com slash the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and youtube
channel 100 percent
advertisement free